si je vous dis friends vous me dites new
york il n'empêche c'est à los angeles
que vous devrez tout de même aller si
d'aventuré vous vouliez rendre visite à
vos amis burbank quartier où sont situés
les mythiques studios warner bros c'est
là du côté d'hollywood que se tourne la
sitcom phare du studio plus précisément
au numéro 24 immense bâtisse dans
laquelle décor comédiens équipes
techniques se côtoient tout au long de
la saison
fabriquée huit mois par an et 12 heures
par jour friends est une machine
infernale et ce n'est pas la moindre de
ses qualités que de proposer une oeuvre
sensible et subtile dans ces conditions
la magie hollywoodienne opère une
nouvelle fois parfois la télévision
accouche d'une petite merveille friends
fait partie de celles là numéro un des
sites comme actuellement aux etats unis
le club des six faire un carton
planétaire depuis le milieu des années
90 raisons majeures elle propose un très
large public de s'associer à ces
aventures friends sur un thème
finalement peu original propose à chacun
de voir à l'écran un petit bout de son
histoire
enfin presque après j'ai entendu dire
que les gens il trouva personnage auquel
il s'identifie à chaque arrêt
téléspectateurs se retrouve dans un des
six amis c'est aussi une période de la
vie qui touche un public un peu plus âgé
ils se souviennent donc vous dire
pourquoi ça marche
la raison essentielle je crois que c'est
parce que c'est marrant ça ne fait quand
même deux grands sujets de conversation
et c'est vrai ça fait donne l'impression
d'appartenir à une communauté sa
première série qui m'a permis de
rencontrer du monde on compte un jean
avec par emma à la fac on le contourne
un amphi de 200 personnes on peut pas
connaître les gens et juste un truc un
gars qui faisaient ça un truc de la
série comme elle est on s'est reconnus
on sait on a parlé après les jeux
puissent un ami
c'est vrai que ça donne beaucoup de sa
donne des éléments à partager avec
d'autres
ça va à dame accompagnée pendant un
moment de ma vie est membre garder phone
si je regarde pas la télévision
ce qui n'est ni sur comme hélène et les
garçons qui parle d'une génération de 20
ans qui coïncide à peu près à ce que moi
je vivais quand j'étais étudiante les
préoccupations principales des
personnages étaient complètement à l'eau
à l'opposé de celle qu'on pouvait avoir
dans la vie de tous les jours c'était
très artificielle est très flou alors
que là il ya toujours un petit détail
qui déclenche les personnages sont très
très humains imparfaits ils sont des
petits défauts de côté sinon tu
wissant - ils sont loin d'être parfait
une fois mal dans leur peau
je crois qu'on peut tous piocher dans
chaque personnage et des éléments
d'éléments qui nous concerne
personnellement on regarde pas friends
comme on regarde une autre série télé
franchement immature là on étudie
beaucoup l'année connaît mac os on est
quand même la génération qui est resté
le plus longtemps chez ses parents donc
finalement c'est pour ça aussi qu'on
adhère à ces deux séries 6 parce que ce
sont des gens immatures mais nous sommes
un peu immature nous restons des grands
enfants
[Musique]